in the opening scene we are introduced
to Sebastian schlenkt vonnert a
mild-mannered bank teller in Potsdam
Germany he feels trapped in his boring
and ordinary life routine but holds a
strong interest in safe cracking he is
currently recording a video for his
newly established YouTube channel during
the video he shares a captivating tale
about a renowned locksmith named Hans
Wagner who crafted a set of four safes
inspired by and named after the four
operas in the ring cycle the reingold
the valkyrie the Siegfried and gatar
Dameron it appears that Wagner designed
these safes in such a way that they
would destroy their contents if anyone
tried to force them open upon completing
the last safe gothardamarang Wagner
sealed himself inside of it forever
despite his colleagues best attempts to
free him they were unsuccessful and
Wagner died inside of the Goddard
amarung that's so fun to say eventually
the safe still unopened was discarded
into the ocean serving as his final
resting place in the present some rumors
persist about the way whereabouts of the
first three safes but none of them are
sure it remains one of the biggest
mysteries in the human world or
Sebastian's just making all this up
for the views with this conclusion
Sebastian uploads the video onto his
YouTube channel but it turns out that
his contents are not gaining any
attention despite being a mastermind in
lockpicking he is yet to crack the
YouTube algorithm upset he shuts his
laptop and prepares himself for another
mundane day at work later on while
dealing with a frustrated customer in
the bank Sebastian stumbles upon news
about a sudden zombie outbreak in
America at the same time he notices
zombie-like behavior in the person he is
assisting so he quickly fulfills her
request and sends her away during his
lunch break Sebastian receives his first
View and comment on his recent YouTube
video from an anonymous person The
Stranger invites him to Showcase his
skills at a specific location providing
an address and a password for entry
intrigued Sebastian decides to visit the
designated place at the appointed time
on reaching there he encounters his
security guard who grants him access
after confirming the password when he
gets inside the dark Warehouse he finds
himself among a safe cracking
competition where he is introduced as
the seventh contestant although
initially puzzled Sebastian excels in
every round and ultimately emerges as
the winner as the crowd cheers for him
he notices a beautiful woman named
Gwendolyn smiling at him here it is
revealed that Gwendolyn is a notorious
Thief who began her life of crime at the
tender age of six she has the ability to
steal jewelry and other precious items
in the blink of an eye currently she is
a wanted criminal the following day
Sebastian goes about his usual routine
when he unexpectedly encounters
Gwendoline Gwendolyn Gwendolyn they talk
over a cup of coffee and Gwendolyn
reveals that she was the one who
commented on his YouTube video wasting
no time she then gets straight to the
point and unveils her plan to rob the
three safes crafted by Wagner Gwendolyn
wants Sebastian to join her team as the
safe cracker due to his unparalleled
knowledge of Wagner's work she then
explains that they have a limited window
of 96 hours before the safes are deep
commissioned hearing all this Sebastian
is stunned but Gwendolyn assures him
that this is the perfect opportunity for
him to escape his boring life she then
leaves the cafe but not before handing
out her business card to him at night we
see Sebastian contemplating the matter
for hours on one hand he thinks the plan
is too dangerous but on the other hand
he wants to feel the thrill of doing
something illegal in the end he decides
to go with a ladder option so he heads
towards the provided address upon
arrival Gwendolyn introduces him to the
rest of the crew which includes this
skilled hacker Karina Dominguez the
getaway driver Rolf and the gunman Brad
cage the team then gets straight to work
and Karina reveals information about the
safes explaining that all three are
owned by a billionaire named Bly Tanaka
and are located in different parts of
the world as the team has no time to
waste they embark on their first heist
in Paris targeting the reingold safe the
scene then shifts shifts the scene then
shifts I can pronounce all these other
languages but not the word shifts the
scene then shifts to the actual robbery
process as per their pre-arranged plan
Sebastian enters the bank first and
discreetly hides in the restroom
Gwendolyn enters next and requests
access to the locker assigned to a false
name Karina then walks in to cause a
diversion that draws the attention of
the staff away from Gwendolyn seizing
this moment Gwendolyn retrieves
Sebastian from his hiding spot and
together they make their way to the
reingold save oncoming face to face with
the legendary safe Sebastian is left in
awe and he talks to it for a while oh
hello munchots but once he is done he
skillfully begins working on the lock
and opens it within a relatively short
time frame after a moment of Celebration
they begin to gather the money while
Sebastian worries about carrying such a
substantial sum Gwendolyn reminds him
that their objective is not merely to
amass wealth but rather to achieve the
feat of cracking the supposedly
impregnable Wagner safes thus attaining
legendary status at last Brad creates a
final distraction within the bank
allowing Sebastian to exit with the
money the triumphant operation instills
Newfound confidence in Sebastian and for
the first time in his life he feels
valued in the next scene we see France
Interpol officers gathering for a
meeting during which an agent named
Della craw examines the details of the
rheingold heist turns out delacroix has
been relentlessly pursuing Brad and
Gwendolyn for Years yet they have
consistently eluded capture in their
most recent encounter delacroix came so
close to apprehending Brad but the
latter shot him before fleeing delacroix
realizes that the crew now has a new
safe cracker and they are plotting to
Target the two remaining safes
presenting him and his team with two
more chances to apprehend them meanwhile
the crew were at their Hideout happily
celebrating their successful first Heist
amidst the festivities Karina approaches
Sebastian and invites him to make out
with her but he declines saying he is
only interested in Gwendolyn hearing
this Karina becomes slightly jealous and
discloses that Gwendolyn is dating Brad
but they are going through a rough patch
currently later that night so Sebastian
goes to Gwendolyn and initiates a
conversation leading them to open up
about their respective pasts Sebastian
shares how his fascination with safe
cracking set him apart from other kids
in his neighborhood while Gwendolyn
recounts her struggles with her wealthy
family and her subsequent decision to
live independently unfortunately Brad
sees them together and becomes real
Angry the next day the crew arrives in
Prague for their second heist targeting
the valkyrie but unbeknownst to them de
la craw and his team have already
arrived there implementing heightened
security measures after rehearsing their
plan Sebastian infiltrates the bank
disguised as a fake employee with Karina
clearing his path by hacking into the
banking system he is then guided towards
the Vault with Gwendolyn closely
guarding him during this the security
guards get suspicious as they see
Sebastian disappear on the cameras
however when they confront them near the
elevator gwendolyn's skillfully takes
them down using her Supreme combat moves
after this the two proceed towards the
safe ready to commence the cracking
meanwhile De La Crosse senses that
something is amiss despite not being
able to pinpoint the exact issue
intrigued by his instincts he decides to
head to the bank however upon reaching
the safe he shockingly discovers that it
does not contain the valkyrie safe he
frantically asks the bank manager about
it and the latter explains that the
valkyrie had been transferred to another
bag for safety this means that Della
craw and his team have ended up in the
wrong location so without wasting any
time they get into their vehicles and
rush to catch the thieves on the other
hand the security guard who noticed
irregularities in the CCTV footage
triggers the security system leading to
the closure of all Bank entrances this
compels the crew to implement Plan B as
a result Brad assumes the role of a
masked robber and enters the building
incapacitating the guards with
tranquilizers in order to provide
Sebastian and Gwendolyn with additional
time seeing the commotion a bank guard
triggers the alarm alerting the
authorities and sealing off all possible
exits in the midst of all this Sebastian
manages to successfully crack the
valkyrie albeit with a few shaky moments
overwhelmed with the achievement he hugs
Gwendolyn tightly and almost kisses her
however their intimate moment is
interrupted by Karina's radio
communication urging them to provide a
status update so that Brad can make his
exit from the bank after giving the
green light Brad attempts to leave but
he is shot in the shoulder by a guard
nevertheless he manages to escape
through a window and make his way to
Rolf and Karina in the getaway van
shortly after Sebastian and Gwendolyn
also come out from the bank just moments
before delacroix and his team arrive at
the scene the two Sprint towards the
waiting van where Brad extends a helping
hand pulling Gwendolyn inside however
driven by jealousy he forcefully pushes
Sebastian away leaving him for the cops
how are you gonna crack the third safe
dumbass now Sebastian finds himself
being pursued by the police so he
quickly grabs a bicycle and makes a run
for it maneuvering through narrow
streets and hidden corners of the town
he fortunately finds his way onto a
train and somehow evades capture but
despite his relief at escaping and the
thrill of his accomplishments he is
overwhelmed by a deep sense of betrayal
meanwhile inside the van Brad and
Gwendolyn engage in a heated argument
Brad justifies his actions arguing that
they had planned to abandon Sebastian
after the heist anyway he also asserts
that they don't have to carry out the
Siegfried Heist anymore as they have
money worth billions billions however
Gwendolyn who at this point had started
liking Sebastian becomes enraged and
decides to leave the van Brad tries to
hold her back confessing his love for
her but she rejects his advances and
departs soon after Karina also joins her
and the two make the decision to find
Sebastian so that they can crack the
Siegfried safe in the next scene
Sebastian returns home only to discover
the girls waiting for him they express
their apology for betraying him
Gwendolyn explains that for Ralph and
Brad The Heist was solely about
financial gain unlike the three of them
who were motivated by the desire to
become legendary thieves known for
cracking the Wagner saves she proposes
that they team up to go for the
Siegfried Sebastian is initial hesitant
as he fears that the girls will betray
him again but when Gwendolyn promises to
never leave his side he agrees the trio
then sets off for Saint Moritz
Switzerland where the Siegfried is
located within a casino this time De La
Crosse chooses a more cautious approach
deciding to wait for the alarms to sound
before moving into apprehend gwendolyn's
Crew He is determined not to give them
an opportunity to escape as they did
previously as a result de la craw and
his team stay patient waiting for a full
eight hours until the safe is relocated
from the casino for decommissioning
during this time De La Crosse team
intercepts a radio transmission between
Karina and Sebastian which reveals that
the heist is scheduled for 5 a.m they
patiently buy their time and precisely
enter the premises at 5am only to
discover that the safe has already been
moved 90 minutes earlier this makes
delacroix realize that Karina
deliberately leaked their communication
to mislead his team and that the safe
has already been stolen elsewhere we see
Gwendolyn and Sebastian on a track with
the latter beginning the process of
cracking the safe at the same time Brad
and Rolf are outside the casino with the
intention of stealing the money from
their former crew they track gwendolyn's
location through her phone and start
pursuing her Karina who is still outside
the casino attempts to stop them but she
instead gets surrounded by delacroix and
his team before surrendering though she
manages to alert Gwendolyn about Brad in
the truck Sebastian successfully unlocks
all Seven Locks of the Siegfried safe
ultimately cracking it open this brings
immense joy for both of them they then
begin packing the money but suddenly
Brad arrives there and interrupts them
he aims his gun at Sebastian and
attempts to shoot but fortunately it
malfunctions Gwendolyn reveals that she
tampered with Brad's weapon earlier
because she suspected he might kill
someone she then retrieves her own
working gun and takes control of the
situation holding Brad and Rolf at
gunpoint at last she handcuffs the bad
guys to the truck before leaving with
Sebastian following their Escape Plan
Gwendolyn and Sebastian reach a boat
before getting off the car Sebastian
obviously expresses his love for
Gwendolyn to which she responds by
kissing him just then delacroix arrives
with a gun in hand he is there to put
them behind bars once and for all
however Gwendolyn who is also pointing a
gun towards him refuses to give up and
engages in negotiation with the officer
she proposes that she will turn herself
in on the condition that Sebastian is
allowed to go free the Lacroix
reluctantly agrees and Gwendolyn
instructs Sebastian to leave she assures
him that they will reunite and pursue
gotta damarang together once she is
released with a heavy heart Sebastian
departs on the boat determined to be
reunited with Gwendolyn in the future
the scene then shifts to sometime to
sometime later where we find Sebastian
is the owner of a locksmith shop named
the Gwendolyn one day two customers
visit Sebastian's store and present him
with a blueprint of gotterdamarong
inviting him to join their team for the
final heist in response Sebastian Simply
Smiles signaling his Readiness to
participate in the final heist subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching